- Hello, I'm Anthony Abeson.
I'm an acting coach.
I've been doing it for,
wow, over 30 years.
Today we're gonna be working
with a few non-actors.
We're gonna give them
emotional result pressure.
We've created one line.
"I'm sorry, I didn't mean
to get so emotional,"
which is pretty clearly
a demand that you get emotional.
Just to make it even more diabolical,
we're gonna ask them
to first try to produce
that emotional result
without any help from me.
- Red leather, yellow leather.
Red leather, yellow leather.
(sighs)
- I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to get so emotional.
(loud thudding)
- Sorry, I didn't mean
to get so emotional.
- I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to get so emotional.
- I really didn't mean
to get that emotional.
(coughs softly)
- I didn't mean to get so emotional.
(laughs)
This is so awkward!
- [Anthony] So who's the most
important person in your life?
You don't even have to say who it is.
- Okay.
- I'm from New York City,
so paying bills is a big thing for me.
Just being able to pay
my rent and my bills,
so I guess that'd be really
sad if I couldn't do that.
- [Anthony] Would you tell me
a little bit about your mom?
- My mother is a teacher,
or was a teacher.
She's a retired teacher now.
- [Anthony] Do you love her?
- Yes.
- As a kid, the idea of having to give
the love of a dog away is just really sad.
- [Anthony] So could you picture
them over here somewhere.
And could you just very softly
say to them, "I love you"?
- I love you.
- I love you, mom.
- [Anthony] Did you ever have a dog?
- I did.
- [Anthony] What was his name?
- His name was Dude.
- [Anthony] What kind of dog?
- He was a little Corgi,
Pembroke Welsh Corgi.
Ate nothing but cheeseburgers
and chicken nuggets.
- [Anthony] What happened to him?
- My parents had to put him down
while I was working at a music festival.
- [Anthony] What would
be the scariest thing
about being homeless?
- I'd be afraid of being beaten up,
or getting taken advantage
of by people on the street.
- [Anthony] I'd like you to
picture a really scary guy
who's looking at you.
Do you worry about them?
- Yes.
- [Anthony] Would you
just worry about them
for a moment, please?
(suspenseful synthesizer music)
- It's intense.
- [Anthony] And he's coming closer to you.
And he's a big, huge, scary guy.
- [Jade] Mm-hm.
- Dude, I miss you.
I'm sorry I couldn't be there for you.
And that I was so close.
But, yeah, that you
had to pass without me.
(melancholic guitar music)
I'm sorry that your last years
you didn't get to see much of me.
But I love you.
- [Anthony] What could happen
to them that you worry about?
There they are in their coffin
and would you just very
softly say goodbye?
- Goodbye.
I love you.
- [Anthony] Say the line, "I'm sorry.
"I didn't mean to get so emotional."
- I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to get so emotional.
- Sorry.
I didn't mean to get emotional.
- I'm sorry, I didn't
mean to get so emotional.
- [Anthony] You started
to believe a little bit?
- [Benjamin] Mm-hm.
- [Anthony] Remember no bad juju.
- It really took me back
to this sensational place
of feeling the weight of his paws
and feeling how his belly felt
that it really kinda allowed
me to connect with that moment.
- I'm more in touch with
my feelings right now.
Just thoughts of different
images, different smells.
- I really felt helpless.
Yeah, with no family, no friends,
and that is completely the
opposite of everything that I am.